bientôt monde c'est spécial jeunes se
retrouvent sur octobre d'épisodes de est
sûrement le dernier épisode arrière on
avait trouvé une banane et on avait eu
la veste maintenant il nous reste à voir
l'octopus d'or je sais pas ce que c'est
et d'équipés l'homme mannequin et là je
suis assis sur un trône arbres sur une
chaise un c'est normal c'est parti hop
ça c'est fait teachers et les big room
c'est fait on pas à la chambre je ne
sais pas c'est qu'elle change d'air
alors est ce que c'est une mission de
noms mais je vais à fait de demander la
fin de la vidéo est plus long tir avec
moi ce qui ne fait absolument pas c'est
par où serait une bonne chose de soi
c'est la selas hélas hélas wapping mais
c'est pas vous si c'est comme ça j'ai
mes choix n'est que ces petits trains a
quand même alors il ya le cauchy le plus
gros du monde avec alain poule je ne
peux pas le laisser partir
ok je peux pas le laisser partir sinon
les monstres vont m'attraper on va
devoir non fait peur des monstres à
poulpe vs monsters qui sera le grand
gagnant alors vos questions d'affaires
tchèque the closet forme monster on doit
juste regarder s'il ya des monstres en
fait c'est ça m'a dit soit tu sais ça
foot à j'hallucine ils attendent avec sa
grande colère des cartons plupart de
pervers alors est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose en bas me dites pas qu'il va
encore être là le vilain monsieur x
hunter qui stoppe ce pas d'offre enrichi
d'un god save the quick habitants et
dernier elle tellement bien fait à quoi
sidney gavignet vienne d'où elles
viennent de là peut-être un peu de vent
non post war et voilà c'est bon donc on
vient de tuer un nlhe et de gagner en
métro une boîte devant ben arfa n'est ni
storybook touring un vol d'armes n'est
pas un livre qui raconte des histoires
en coin à voir à temps ok elle est
excités nerveux pas du monde
ok on va devoir remplacer son doudou
sans se faire cramer au elle dort bien
qu'elle est mignonne au elle le sera
encore plus quand elle verra une grosse
cote boulbon se réveillant à là dedans
et oran [ __ ] de cov de jouer à la
ficam qui trop bien haut mais dégage
il est où ce [ __ ] de d'enfants dites
le moi là mais je mens
je chope tous les jouets de la caisse
sauf le dauphin mais [ __ ] ok tu veux
jouer à ça avec moi je rentre dans la
caisse je prends comme ça va être
impossible de faire faut remplacer le
aller vite sinon on va être repérés au
tu te vois pas que c'est vrai un
objectif et en plus ça c'est le cri de
joie du football
mission accomplie eh ben on peut s'en
aller c'est parfait sans être vu j'ai
peur du [ __ ] pâtissier là qui va notre
peau je pense qu'il est repéré qu'on
était un tout et une opinion à bille le
mannequin il est où le mannequin je
crois qu'on va avoir un problème il est
où le mannequin assez ça c'était pas mon
saut 300 kg d'inciter leurs c'était un
mannequin d'accor prend ça un mois le
foot d'accord beaucoup non on s'habille
en deux comme il est beau à regarder le
connais un peu plus si tu es vraiment
ici alors j'ai ma place et ce test oh
[ __ ] il va douter sur robben en
dessous de 100 escalade cette échelle le
cauchemar pour messieurs poule c de ce
qu'elle a dit les chaînes allez je te
plaise pas demandé non monsieur poulpe
c'est bon tel un diable on passe à table
qu'est ce qui vous fait
allez
hi lo make you et de procès toute
franchise
non mais non mais non ben non c'est non
est-ce que tu espèce d'idiot
mon mari m'a dit oui j'aime pas ta vie
ta coiffe aussi mignon on retrouve notre
famille est originaire de trésors chérie
tu t'es bien habillé pour moi et ça me
rappelle le thym le moment ces
rencontres et tu te souviens je me
souviens de tous les détails
je crois qu'on a fini on n'a plus qu'à
s'amuser à obtenir un taux resté scotché
devant la tv là haut comment tu me
parles sur ce ton octobre
mais pourquoi tu dors comme ça tu veux
faire un bien avec moi s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je suis gentil
moi je joue avec mon dos voilà comme ça
j'aime bien je n'ai pas besoin de qui
j'ai ma jambe regarder
cet hôtel sert à rien elle dit juste
coucou guen vient avec sarko
ce qui est super agent donc je sais
pouvoir la fabrique maintenir et se sert
à rien fait pendant trois ou quatre
rappels en fait vous êtes nuls en toi